I've got about an hour before
I need to head out for school pick up
which always coincides with the time of the day
where I'm the most tired that I've ever been
in my entire life
and I find that the only thing that helps me with
that is a little snacky snack
I started by making a smoothie with some frozen banana
Ceres organics cacao powder
protein powder dates oats
ice and oat milk
And because I've got a major sweet tooth
especially at this time of the day
I'm gonna need a little treat
all three flavours of the Ceres Organic Fudgy Bites
are legitimately delicious
but today I'm going for the chocolate raspberry because it's my favourite
they decadent but also wholesome
because they made out of organic whole food ingredients
but tasting them you wouldn't know it cause they do taste kind of naughty
I think it's probably the rich chocolatey taste and the soft fudge centre
that's doing it it really does feel like a treat
but I know it's good for me
so I'm pleased about that
so I'm gonna do a little admin and enjoy my delicious moment of self care
before the chaos of the afternoon shift begins